even when a conspiracy theory says
absolutely nothing true about the object
of the theory if it catches on it says
something true about the anxieties and
the experiences of the people who
believe it hi I'm Nicholas ray with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Jesse Walker he's the books editor at
Reason magazine reason.com and he's the
author of the great new book the United
States of paranoia a conspiracy theory
which is out from HarperCollins Jesse
thanks for talking to us so glad to talk
to you at the heart of this book is
conspiracy theory in American politics
is it a new phenomenon is it right wing
is a left wing where where are we with
conspiracy a political paranoia and
conspiracy theories in particular have
been a part of the United States since
before there was a United States going
back to the colonial era across the
political spectrum left wing right wing
and the center it's we're not just
talking about people and the fringes or
outsiders but often people at the very
heart of American power
so talk John Quincy Adams for instance
was what was his bent noir well he comes
up a couple times in the book but the
one that really interests people is that
he was a anti Mason he was afraid of the
influence of Freemasonry in the 1832
election he made a comment that the most
important thing isn't whether a mr.
Jackson or mr. clay is elected but what
we can do about the Masonic institution
the Masonic power what was he so worried
about what's the basis the anti-masonic
impulse comes from a number of different
directions I think in his case it was a
sort of sincere fear of the the the
influence that people meeting behind
closed doors could have I mean I mean
it's the same sort of impulse that had
people afraid of party politics at the
beginning of the of the United States a
bit of course the different people were
that jumped onto anti masonry for
different reasons Andrew Jackson he was
president he was a Mason if you were
against Jackson this was obviously one
way to direct opposition in the cradle
of anti masonry upstate New York there
was a very famous incident where
somebody William Morgan said he was
going to reveal Masonic secrets and then
was apparently
and killed and that led to charges of a
cover-up and this was in a context in
which I mean some historians have gone
back and showed that actually in a lot
of these communities there was heavy
overlap between people who are involved
with Freemasonry and people who were
involved with you know the higher
reaches of local societies in a
democracy are conspiracy theories more
active in the sense that you know we're
supposed to have open government or
transparent government and so are people
more worried about kind of dark shadowy
forces directing things I don't know if
it I think it's a different kind of
worry I mean obviously in monarchies
there's always the court intrigue you
know I mean and there's a long history
of you know the English being afraid of
Spanish conspiracies and vice versa you
know often there were really were spies
you know but I think that there's a
different flavor in a Democratic Society
what are some of the other conspiracy
theories kind of the the real classics
that you talk about in the book well one
of my favorites was the attempted
assassination of Andrew Jackson in 1835
Jackson himself believed that a senator
from Mississippi had arranged for or
attempted to arrange a hit on him
some of the projects and people jumped
on this at the same time auntie Jackson
people were claiming it was a false flag
attack that he had arranged for somebody
to fire at him but that's why the
pistols had failed was because he just
wanted public sympathy Lyndon Johnson
when the riots in the mid sixties were
hitting was convinced that the
Communists were behind it or strongly
suspected that the Communists were
behind it he asked his cabinet for
evidence to back this up the Attorney
General told him the evidence wasn't
there he was basically keep looking so I
mean it happens you know throughout
American history no part of the inside
of the book is that you know that
conspiracy theories as you were saying
or not fringe phenomena they're actually
at the center of American politics what
do we gain by looking at conspiracy
theories or if not taking the the
conspiracy seriously at least looking at
why do people keep returning to
conspiracy as a way of explaining things
well I think that even when a conspiracy
theory says absolutely nothing true
about
the object of the theory if it catches
on it says something true about the
anxieties and the experiences of the
people who believe it
if you look for example a when back in
the 1980s there is a spate of belief
that no white doctors were injecting
black babies with AIDS right I mean this
is not true right I mean I'm not gonna
claim it's true it's not but this comes
that you know and you can see how this
could catch on among people who've had
to deal with a long history of abusive
or high-handed treatment from white
doctors and why this sort of you would
sort of reach for something that
mythically expresses you know day to day
experience something similar also would
be a lot of new world order theories you
could see how people who feel like
they're losing control over their lives
would be attracted to ideas about a
cabal plotting against American liberty
and sovereignty and so on what is the
relevance of the book today what does
what does it offer a reader besides I
mean I an absolutely rollicking and
interesting and kind of you know
gimlet-eyed view of American history I
mean I think people will find it
fascinating for that but you know what
is its relevance to contemporary
American readers no I mean first I do
try to make it very entertaining so that
people could read it and enjoy it and
get a nothing ahead of it but I think
I'm trying to provide a tool kit I'm
trying to show these stories that keep
getting told again and again
I mean sometimes the same narratives
with different names plugged in and why
they've come up in the past and what
kind of in the circumstances they've
come up under so that when they turn up
again you won't say oh geez birthers
that's something that we've never heard
of before you know actually you know
there is precedent for this how did you
come to get interested in conspiracy
theory as a as a subject of inquiry well
I guess I in my teens I was reading
books about you know I mean actual sane
well-documented books about abuses by
the CIA and the FBI and so forth I mean
often drawing on the investigations that
were done in the 1970s and these were
often on the same shelves as somewhat
kookier books by you know people like
Fletcher Prouty you know making these
sort of stranger claims if I started
reading those and actually at first
thinking you know
this will be more you know more grist
for the mill and then I start saying you
know actually the level of evidence here
is not quite as good but it was
interesting and in its own right they
were interesting as stories and ran the
same time actually I discovered you know
some things like in the Church of the
SubGenius you know books by Robert Anton
Wilson and people who were in the book I
call them the the ironic style of
American paranoia people who are
interested in conspiracy theories not so
much as something to be espoused or
debunked but as just a sort of great
mutant mythos that you can have fun with
and just sort of build these great
stories and and just sort of find what
metaphors or laughs or insights or are
inside them and and and I in in some
ways I'm trying to extend that tradition
here I mean I'm looking at these stories
that people have told and I'm I'm not
making up a conspiracy theory of my own
but I'm saying what can what can we
unearth from these stories do you think
you know now with revelations about NSA
you know massive NSA surveillance and
other kinds of intelligence state
operations going on are we at the
beginning of another phase like in the
70s when the Church Commission hearings
and what not really unearthed for the
first time and gave documented facts you
know are evidence that there was a lot
of spying going on a lot of surveillance
a lot of conspiratorial work on the part
of government or quasi government actors
are we gonna go through another cycle of
you know really kind of airing
conspiratorial laundry oh I hope so I
mean I mean I'm all in favor of
investigative journalism and
congressional probes that bring to light
genuine abuses of power the flip side of
the NSA thing is that we're also seeing
an intense paranoia on the part of the
government I mean this war on leakers
that we're seeing right now is megive
intime you know there is an enemy that's
sort of being that that's inspiring
people at the center of power or more
than one enemy and right now there's
this intense fear of its of themselves
of itself of what will people working
for the government turn around and tell
other people and this is in some ways a
more interesting paranoia than the
paranoia of people are afraid of the NSA
I mean people at the center of
or are constantly having their own fears
in this case possibly justified although
I think the leaks are great but I think
it's it's you know we're probably coming
yeah alright well we'll leave it there
Jesse Walker the author of the United
States of paranoia a conspiracy theory
by it now it's an incredible read Jesse
thanks for talking to us take for reason
TV I'm Nicholas
[Music]
you